I want to talk about her phrase I heard
recently manspreading yes do you know
Andy you don't man's fighting it yeah
it's like when someone sits I got a bus
or in a subway in a public place and
like they just a guy spreads his legs
yeah
takes up too much room it's it's just an
employee yeah yeah I've seen it yeah
exactly
folks if you're in public sharing a
common space the least that you should
do excuse me sir you in the front row
[Laughter]
yes you did you hear what we're talking
about over here
yeah yeah it was funny no no do you
think maybe you could close your legs a
bit no I'm good thank you no no
seriously what you're doing is really
impolite
can you just close your legs that's a no
can do you know I have long legs and my
boys need the extra space you know they
like to fly first class I'm not gonna
stick them in code okay look if you're
not gonna close your legs
I'll have them closed for you guys would
to help me out here yeah seriously we
have stage hands touch my leg yeah yeah
there's a troll that's yeah I'm right
that's the way it should be and it's
much much better all right moving on
ladies and gentlemen over the weekend
the latest democratic debate was held in
Flint Michigan both Hillary Clinton and
Bernie Sanders heads oh for God's sake
sir keep your legs
I tried it's just not comfortable okay
that this is what works for me why is
that freak right thing here legs right
there yes you sir juicers on the road
you know we were we see that I was no it
was you
now getting back to the keeps doing it
continued you can't have your legs on
other people get them off those people's
laps okay man it is just I know it we
were just talking about it and and it's
so ironic that it's happening yeah it's
just absurd such an incredible level of
evasion of everyone's face anyway the
Democratic debates are supposed to show
the differences between Hillary Bernie
Oh
[Applause]
I'm doing everything you ask me to do
throwing it I'm trying to be comfortable
during your shower we'll get this
straightened out during the break it's
discussing what you're doing why can't
you accommodate me I've
[Laughter]
you